how's it goin bread - parrot back
welcome back to blight [ __ ]
town gonna try this episode that's as
far as [ __ ] much we'll see how that
goes
these are so easy to kill like I don't
even understand why they exist okay here
we are
I guess this place is new I don't like
this eight four three board a Fiat a
scarlet way poor defectors better
develop oh hey do you come here often
real really every single time in the
last episode all I did was die from
falling and being an idiot but that's
God okay we're fine we didn't fall 10
points for Griffin died he's ain't no
Harry Potter [ __ ] don't fall down don't
what
run run Oh God Oh God
where do I go where do I go why am I
here
don't fall down don't fall down you
can't come with me
stop following me stop I know you love
me but let's gotta let go man you gotta
let go
Dalila Leah she stick up everywhere oh
yes ck everybody we're all right I can't
do anything about you you piece of [ __ ]
or can I
yes okay I can't okay whoa I jumped on
his face and kill them awesome what is
going on
whoa somersault although a [ __ ] cross
the sky no not today
go home to Canada I don't know why I
said that Canadian bros are gonna be
like a bit but but why but we don't look
like that
you sure well it's the last time you
look at in the mirror I'm just sayin now
what is this a suicide pole are you you
can't follow me oh this is too good to
be true
I just wanna poop on you it'll be like a
heavenly touch I'll just be chillin on
the ladder if anyone needs anything it's
good you guys need exercise it's great
come here I swear to god that's the best
way to fight them you may call it cheap
you may call it cheating I call it their
fat I don't care it's nothing wrong a
bit against being fat that just means
you love food and I mean [ __ ] doesn't
trust me you haven't seen my belly
it looks like Gordon Freeman valet of
Drake's yeah that's not gonna be good is
it we did it
bright Blighttown high five the bonfire
would be
I'm gonna take a break I know it's hard
to just hold down the [ __ ] thumb
stick straightforward everyone else is
how you walk in the mountains God like
you don't know anything
see if I can make it inside nailed it
that's what
no one said it shut up hi hello Nando I
oh stop being a [ __ ] I think pink too
for that matter
goddamn racist I don't know if I trust
the elevator but sometimes in life you
just gotta try to go with your instincts
oh cool so we open up a shortcut i you
bros suggested that I [ __ ] with this guy
he looks so sexy and I have no [ __ ]
clue how to kill it you don't even have
a butt man how do you go to the bathroom
oh he lost a leg I didn't realize that
that's pretty awesome
he lost his face too hey what why are
you going man thought we had a deal you
die I get your loot don't [ __ ] up just
because he has a little health just
kidding you thought I was gonna [ __ ] up
I never [ __ ] up except all the [ __ ]
time today come on humanity I am a whole
month look at that sexy face okay we're
gonna do some farming here in the woods
not really a lot of enemies down here
damn this guy looks tough [ __ ] come on
yes oh why thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you are even now a
football soccer ball no one cares you're
almost there
don't fall this [ __ ] down man I
should get in it oh oh we can't go there
oh [ __ ] I'm I [ __ ] came is that a
fact man dead he's not dead he's not
dead we're friends right I wasn't trying
to stab you oh god I'm so screwed good
night you sleep again now I said sleep
you want to go for a bath yep it's the
butterfly what where is it oh god it's
Guardian
hein God daddy soon
face butterfly look at it ganja it's
beautiful oh good I don't know what is
that gonna do almost [ __ ] kill me
that's what it's gonna do mad beautiful
gorgeous butterfly stop shooting me with
lasers when do I get my chance to attack
you just get a shield there aren't you
well I think oh god oh god oh god plant
me mr. butterfly why don't you just come
and take a nap yeah that's for a
butterfly right there right here right
now
Oh what the [ __ ] oh oh oh such beauty
such power such gay such fabulous that's
all I get his [ __ ] soul wow that was
fun okay so Chris after some not
cheating I found out that I missed a
bossing blight on
hi guys don't mind me I said don't mind
me I'm not doing this [ __ ] two more
today [ __ ] a blacked out just wanna make
it to the [ __ ] bonfire man now how
the [ __ ] do I make it back down there
hopefully this won't kill me probably
they went oh god don't forget to jump
off okay we need to go over there how
the [ __ ] that shit's gonna work it's
beyond me you bet
Oh God Oh what the [ __ ] I wasn't ready
for a fatty fat fat okay
oh thanks this looks like Oh God what
the [ __ ]
god that's disgusting mate how the [ __ ]
are those things bye-bye oh there's
Peter people Oh oh god they do so much
damage is he praying for me to kill him
oh man that's [ __ ] up this is gonna be
bad Oh
fired Oh God what are we gonna see boobs
goddamn hair do you come here often I
have no idea how to fight this [ __ ] I
actually don't want to fight this [ __ ]
cause she spits lava and [ __ ] that's
cool a sham deranged yeah dance and
range what about it at the end
Oh insta-kill what don't sama bitchin
yes that's something to learn I guess
oh come on that's not nice man I don't
know what you think nice is but that is
definitely not a back I'm [ __ ]
sucking hey let's kill this [ __ ]
[ __ ] but first we gotta jump the mud
this is so [ __ ] dumb that you have to
do this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh hey that's uh
how are that not so great are they
alright let's kill this [ __ ] one boss
place what thought is [ __ ]
missed me [ __ ]
mismatch Oh
throw up on me [ __ ] bury you
you like it don't you daddy's [ __ ] whoa
she dismissed me by a lock holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Oh Oh back off back the [ __ ] off Oh
[ __ ] that was close
now's your chance Oh God guacamole you
can't throw up in your throw up Oh God
Oh God we're so close don't [ __ ] up
don't [ __ ] up don't [ __ ] [ __ ] up [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off [ __ ] Fah Fah Fah Fah you're
gonna die and I'm gonna eat you
literally disgusting actually never mind
there's just like you guys don't slap
[ __ ]
that's right you [ __ ] ass oh I have her
soul oh that [ __ ] felt good
Oh all those souls I [ __ ] dominated in
that [ __ ] the level design is so cool
like it doesn't matter how far and deep
you go somewhere and always intertwines
in some cool way I rang the bell cool to
bring the two bells now one deep down in
one farah someone awakes that doesn't
look very pleasant I think this is sense
fortress yeah it is I heard about this
place and I heard it's not very nice so
let's go there whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
calm down let me read it what a
welcoming all right Fred's gonna have to
end another episode of here but I hope
you enjoyed watching they were like if
you did I really appreciate all the
support hits the sky to come to earth
today I'll see you Bruce in the next one
stay awesome love you
sorry Canadians I didn't mean to offend
you or fat people right now we're
talking man hahaha
[Music]